NARRATOR: The Hindu god Vishnu
is the protector of creation,
and Angkor Wat
was built for him.
Inside the temple
are over 12,000
square feet of intricately
carved reliefs.
One relief was created
to link King Suryavarman
II to Vishnu himself.
Look, you can
see that by relief,
the king who built this temple.
And if you look
closely over there,
there is an inscription saying,
[non-english speech]
Meaning that he is
the king who went
to the highest world of Vishnu.
NARRATOR: Archaeologists
aren't sure whether the king
is buried here.
But local people believe
that his spirit resides
here in Vishnu's paradise.
That paradise, that
heaven, lies at the top
of the central tower.
DAVID: So they believed
that Suryavarman
II's spirit would inhabit
these towers in the afterlife.
Exactly.
If you look at the steps,
like the wide of the step,
why it's too narrow?
It can be implied, the ideas
of that approaching the worlds
of God is not that easy.
All right.
Well, let's not wait
a moment longer.
Let's go up.
Please, go.
NARRATOR: The peak of the
temple was believed by the Khmer
to be the highest reaches of
heaven and the realm of Vishnu
himself.
David, what do you think?
I think that everyone is
impressed by your ancestors.
This is phenomenal.
Perhaps they were
building such immaculate,
beautiful structures to
entice the gods to inhabit
the structures so that
the priests, the king
would have had this opportunity
to have a direct connection
with the supernatural.
That's true.
Even if you're not
a spiritual person,
you can feel the aura
of this kind of place.
We really are at
heaven on earth.
Mm-hmm.
[music playing]